Joe Biden officially announced that he's
running again Donald Trump officially
announced that he's running again
in if that's the matchup who do you
think wins
if the election's held today
I think Biden
why well first of all I believe he won
last time
and if I start with the results from
2020 and I think to myself what has
happened since then that would push or
pull voters one way or the other
I have a hard time making a case that
Trump is in a better position today than
he was in November of 2020.
so that's kind of my starting point
which is it's a rematch of an election
with a known outcome
what has changed
and I can't make a case for
circumstances having changed in Trump's
favor to give a couple of state level
examples Florida seems to be kind of
moving more to the Republican side since
2020 but Trump won that state already in
2020 so it wouldn't really change the
outcome Arizona was close I think
Arizona has moved to the left since 2020
so I don't see Trump taking that one
Wisconsin I think the same sort of thing
applies so being very like practical
that would be kind of the start of my
reasoning
do you think Joe Biden is a better
candidate now than he was
in 2020.
I think
he's a worse candidate
this is going to sound ageist but I
think he's a worse candidate in that
he's even older and there already seems
to be an appetite for younger candidates
particularly on the Democratic voting
side so he's going to be four years
older and in a sense that could be a
liability
however he also is going to have four
years of accomplishments now you might
not like the things he's done in which
case that would hurt him but he has
started to accumulate
um not insignificant number of
accomplishments some of the big things
that are known inflation reduction act
and covet stimulus you know but also
less well-known things like a bunch of
little tweaks to Health Care a bunch of
little tweaks to student lending there's
been a lot of little things
um at the macro level I don't actually
think Joe Biden has that much to do with
this the same way I didn't credit or
attack Trump for a lot of the
macroeconomic stuff but inflation has
started to come down significantly the
stock market's quite steady these sort
of things I think looking historically
it's a pretty okay environment for Joe
Biden with the exception that he was
already the oldest president to be
inaugurated in 2021 and he would beat
his own record in January of 2025 and I
just don't know how voters are going to
see that
so in terms of just a public human being
how would you compare Trump and Biden so
if I were to give criticism towards
trump it would be that he's chaotic
maybe to the point of being
disrespectful to a lot of different
groups to a lot of different ideas to a
lot of different nations and leaders and
all that kind of stuff and then the
criticism towards Biden would be that he
'd maybe perhaps because of age or any
other kind of cognitive capabilities is
not really there mentally as a
you know in the way that perhaps you
could say like Barack Obama was there
just mentally being able to handle all
kinds of aspects of being a public
representative of a Nation to the world
and to the people of that Nation so
which uh in the competition of
Personality flaws which do you think is
more powerful you've laid out
fair and I believe accurate assessments
of elements of both of those uh men yeah
you haven't weighed in on to what degree
you value each of those assessments
which is where I think the the kind of
meat of this question really is
um I don't see and I know that you know
Biden's going to get us into World War
III World War Three that doesn't seem to
be happening
um I don't see
the Biden deficits you listed which I
agree with you on I don't see them as
um
dangerous or threatening to the standing
of the United States
in this kind of environment with our
Western traditional Western allies and
geopolitics
Etc in the way that the sort of unhinged
personality of trump combined with his
lack of knowledge about most issues is a
threat so for me if those two are the
candidates
Biden would be my choice now are there
people I would rather see on the
Democratic side yes if I knew the
president would be a republican can I
think of better options than Trump
absolutely you know I think it's it's so
funny when in 2012 it was Obama versus
Romney the difference seemed so
significant between them thinking back
I'm sure I would disagree with Mitt
Romney about tax rates and his views on
LGBT or I'm sure I I know are different
than mine but it seems without looking
at him with rose-colored glasses so
comparatively benign given the the four
years of trump so that's kind of where I
come down even uh McCain and Obama the
the differences seemed quite drastic
yeah McCain was interesting because
Palin as his running mate opened the
door to the sort of cartoonish stuff
that we've started to see on the
Republican side Palin Trump Margery
Taylor green it started going in that
direction which has made the party a bit
of a joke aside from what you believe
the tax rate would be right you can say
taxes are too high but Jewish space
lasers come on you know so uh but but I
I agree with you on McCain also